when I started my calling it something
else besides you know making out with
that's the goop lab we are in science
lab here and what we have are lots of us
you can see shiny stainless steel stuff
and in here we measure force fields and
in here we measure energy fields between
individual atoms and between atoms and
molecules we move atoms and molecules
around we've done loads or sixty symbols
videos and moving atoms and molecules
around this lab has goes by the
incredibly sophisticated title of ear
103 nothing more to read into it there's
no numerology there it was on my radar
it's not something I would generally sit
down and watch but given that this one
is all about energy and energy fields
and the double slit experiment is
mentioned and a number of years back we
did something else you remember Brady on
quantum whoa I really wanted to take a
look and that's what we're gonna do now
we're gonna sit down and I'm well I
stand up and just watch it looks like a
lot of fun very attractive people doing
very attractive things
okay let's just pause for a second okay
the following series is designed to
entertain and inform not provide medical
advice okay well that's a good
disclaimer to have upfront you should
always consult your doctor when it comes
to your personal health but before you
start any treatment as both of us know
Brady however if you put stuff in the
video information on a video often the
vast majority of times it's ignored
okay so that's actually okay in terms of
the four point six percent of matter in
fact physicists have got a really
embarrassing problem in that they don't
know what the vast majority the universe
is made up of in terms of where we are
in terms of what we're doing in terms of
what they're doing up 4.6 percent is
pretty much everything so let's okay
what type of energy are we talking
kinetic energy electromagnetic energy
acoustic energy potential energy what
type of energy this is this is already
beginning to wind me up
so it's the same old tropes and the same
ol means so that idea of everything
being one integrated whole and how we're
all connected energetically etcetera
etcetera okay every century is basically
the age of energy energy drives pretty
much everything what I don't want to do
for a change is come across as
absolutely and utterly well this is just
nonsense and they inform scientists
ridiculing everything if there's a
placebo element of this if there's a
therapeutic element of this perhaps you
could argue from that perspective that
some of this might have some value but
let's let's see where it goes okay this
is bondage
okay we can't let that one go I had an
exorcism if we're talking about
exorcisms this pups might not be the
most educational but let's go only got
to the titles and more money pissed off
you have energy that's bound up in the
muscles and ligaments and spine and
facha and organs when you're under
stress so I show up and actually
influence how energy is moving okay so
energy is a really important concept in
physics and energy very broadly speaking
is the ability to do work but it comes
in so many different forms and to a
certain extent what he's saying the
first part of that is light in terms of
biochemical energy and your body in
terms of your muscles it's mechanical
energy and biomechanical energy there
but how is he influenced on that energy
that's that's the question is it
possible that some of the problem though
is just like misappropriation of the
word like if they're if they're talking
about something different but they're
calling it energy and you're getting all
wound up like is that is that is all the
problem possibly tracked back to that I
don't think all the problem tracks back
to that certainly what I've read online
about this that's the all of the
problems not tripod that's a really
really good point
Brady let me just pick something up can
I put this down it's not okay for a
second okay no work has been done on
this particular party I've lifted it up
against gravity I returned it to the
same position so no net work has been
done on this particular body of course
I've you know my muscles have had to do
various things and has been energy
expended there but it we have to be
really really careful how we define
different terms for a physicist in a
professional context work is the dot
product of the force and displacement
vectors are the integral of the dot
product of the force and displacement
vectors that's obviously not what it's
me you know if I say you've been working
9:00 to 5:00 Brady that's obviously not
what's brings to mind so yes we have to
be careful with language but the problem
is we physicists have to take some of
the blame because we import everyday
language it's not just the people I
there who aren't physicists
misinterpreting this I would say we are
very guilty in propagating quite a lot
of corn
move and let's see what this goes so I
show up and actually influence how
energy is moving so that your body can
heal faster and your physical being your
emotional being your mind your soul I'm
just gonna have to stop at that point
because this is meant to be what I just
like is the goop lab so there's a
scientific shame forgetting about that
disclaimer at the start and I don't
think you know that disclaimer is really
gonna impact to have young people and
now we're talking about the soul within
a scientific context okay I do I have to
stop it there what what the hell do we
mean by frequency of vibration what sort
of a sort of push myself for a push
Brailey
you know does he what what do we talk
what frequency of vibration but you know
what is this and again this is importing
just as you said Brady this is importing
particular language of physics and
misinterpreting that in an everyday
context of course we talk about
frequency in in physics so much quantum
physics right at the heart of quantum
physics we've got a very simple equation
which is e is equal to H nu or hich F
there's a direct relationship between
energy and frequency but the problem is
that's then couched in terms of when
you're on the same frequency as me and
you know very very everyday almost
mundane language and when we start to
mix these terms that's when it gets
dangerous just before we started talking
about the soul my concern is that when
he seems to be couching this as a valid
medical process but you said yourself
you know you can come to work and have a
talk about frequency and then you can go
home and talk to your loved ones and use
frequency in a different context and
that's not a problem so why are you
calling him on it because he's cutting
us in a scientific context whether he's
doing that deliberately and whether
Paltrow was doing it deliberately I
don't know it's tough the part of the
you know that's out there and Paltrow I
think she believes this stuff that guy
in terms of what he's doing does he
really believe he's affecting people
maybe he
is he doing this deliberately using that
language deliberately or to put that
scientific sheen on or does he just
genuinely believe that I don't know
things like magnet therapy laser therapy
light therapy vibrational therapy how
they're manipulating the energetic field
of a person to heal or break up tissue
etc I just the energetic they never
defined it I've been hesitant to show it
just because it it can look strange yeah
it's no no you cannot no you cannot no
you cannot be licensed sure that you're
giving up warm you know a red radiation
but in terms of influencing not to that
extent were the body's doing this that's
an energy field he claims to be
influencing so that he can control
emotional responses to that extent via
infrared but he even if he'd mentioned
infrared at some point that might be
useful but what is that energy field is
it possible you just don't know and he's
he has found something and he's able to
move through that something but you just
don't understand okay so let's say um
okay that's his theory I've got my
theory let's say all human emotions are
couched in terms of completely
undetectable nanoscopic rings or energy
midi-chlorian something like
midi-chlorians but they exist out there
and let's say that love lets
Wynd in some good physics terminology
love is due to the constructive
interference with those rings and here
it is due to the destructive influence
interference with all things they've not
been detected yet and actually their
energy scale is such that we just could
never detect them
prove me wrong definitively prove me
wrong but he's got people he has got
people wobbling around he's got people
saying hey I feel better and so we need
empirical evidence because the placebo
effect is exceptionally strong we do
trials of drugs where we build in the
placebo effect this is a combination of
placebo effect
palter personality he's a fairly
attractive and charismatic guy I would
say and he's clearly very eloquent and
he's clearly
got people hanging off his every word
does a huge number of confounding
variables here there are layers multi
demint in what sense honestly that's a
word that's loaded and I'm interacting
with those layers so when i moving my
hands in the air and i would snap my
fingers and i'm making sounds with my
hands i'm putting energy into the field
[Music]
[Music]
right so he said he's influencing the
person at the subatomic level by
clicking his fingers if we could
influence matter at the subatomic level
by clicking our fingers we wouldn't have
to spend billions on cern we wouldn't
have to and we wouldn't need this bloody
thing no this is just nonsense this
really is just nonsense and you know the
argument will be made well science
doesn't know everything so you know how
do you know
sure science doesn't know ever then if
science new ever then I'd be out of a
job
Brady would be out of a job because
everything would be out there but
science knows some things and the way
that science works is that we have to
have empirical measurements and we have
to have evidence if we don't have
evidence and you know physicists are
pretty bad I am no fan of the multiverse
because what is what empirical evidence
have we got for the multiverse
hypothesis zilch is what this guy is
doing you know aligned with that to a
certain extent in that he's proposing
something with no empirical evidence it
is so I will stress that we really don't
want to come across as a physicist on
his high horse you know
spikes off about New Age waste off the
way I'm doing that but we physicists do
have to take some other blame but fill
science works by collecting evidence and
having a hypothesis and working through
these different procedures but that
that's not how nature works so for
example I don't know how my car works
but I know when I press the accelerator
it
is it possible that you don't know and
even he doesn't know how the human body
energy field works but he's just
stumbled across the fact that when he
clicks his fingers in a certain location
it cures people just like I know when I
press the accelerator the car works I
don't know why but I know it does ok is
this repeatable if we do this under
controlled experimental conditions can
he do this so for one thing I would love
to see he's talking his way through him
you can hit the hands are clicking
around what have we were to put a
blindfold on people and whatever put a
headphones on and do it an entirely
darkened room he says it works up to six
six feet away I think somewhere between
three and six feet away completely
isolate the person
don't give them any hints as to where
his hands are or what he's doing and
let's then see what the motions are but
maybe it works because it's him maybe
maybe his quantum energy field chakra is
what makes it work and therefore it's
not repeatable by you because you
haven't blown out here so I'm saying use
him the question is let's cut out
external stimuli and see if this still
works let's see if they're doing all
this motion or that is solely due to
suggestion and the placebo fire and we
know how strong right does bollocks
sorry but that is bollocks
the idea that you might have to bleep a
lot but really truly author Lee complete
bollocks the man is talking out of his
nether regions that has not been
empirically proved beyond a shadow of a
doubt so irritating Lee and
frustratingly some scientists have
actually have cleared this some very
important visitors including Heisenberg
himself what we don't have that evidence
we do not that evidence is not there
there are probably at last count
something like 25 different theories of
quantum mechanics and there's no other
interpretations of quantum mechanics and
there's
no empirical evidence that definitively
says this one is important over this one
is information important yes it seems to
be is knowing the trajectories of
particles and how that plays into
unknown the history of particles and
indeed even future of particles does all
of that play into quantum mechanics yes
do we understand the matter yes can we
do incredibly sophisticated calculations
and predict what happens in the real
world yes do we understand it no and
physicists really what really winds me
up is when physicists present something
as sort of a fait accompli and this
happens all the time particularly you
know things like many worlds that's one
interpretation of quantum mechanics
multiverse that's one interpretation of
physics in terms of empirical evidence
for either normal doesn't mean we can't
talk about them doesn't absolutely
doesn't mean we can't talk about it and
the thing is I'm going to cut this guy
some slack here for a change because
when you have physicists of the caliber
of Heisenberg and indeed Martin Rees
Mirman those type of people basically
saying without any real qualification
yes consciousness is so important for
quantum mechanics can you blame this guy
or can you blame people like Deepak
Chopra and that under like for taking
this on board and you know as I say we
physicists really are sort of
propagating our own little quanta of
whoo every time we get up and we don't
make it really really clear actually we
don't fully understand this
Oh of information between the brain
nervous system and muscles this I know
I'm all interrupting a lot but this is
business really the crux of this how is
he doing that really how is he doing
that and you know if we were to feel I
walk in here and I don't know how you're
doing stuff but I believe you're doing
huh you tell me you tell me that in that
machine you've manipulated atoms and
you've moved them and you show me a
picture on a screen but I don't know you
did it but you could sit here and you
could watch every single step of that
process in fact you could say he's doing
that he's letting us watch his process
no he's not so what what's not what I
can show you exactly from the point of
here's how we measure the current this
is the instrument we use to measure the
current this is the way I do it is I
move my hand here and I feel an energy
here and I click my fingers what type of
energy and how is he influenced on it
but you know you do know because I've
bored you know but I can show you that
current I can show you that measurement
we can we can get a meter and we can see
that current okay you're not convinced
but I'm watching him move his hand and
then I'm saying the people on the bed go
and move around and have their little
okay exorcism and like and and there are
multiple explanations for it but you
can't say that he hasn't shown if I go
I'm influence in my quantum fields Brady
do you believe me no I personally don't
so what's the difference tween me and
him apart from he's much more attractive
as much more hair okay that's a really
great example know that there's a really
what we were talking about earlier Brady
in terms of energy being used in this
sense of positive and negative emotional
energy as compared to a physical entity
that that that's a real issue here in
terms of confusing those two contexts
very different contexts in terms of
politics it's not it's not in this
context where he's he's arguing that
he's gonna make people feel better by
changing their energy fields so there's
a question of the physical energy field
being confused for the emotional energy
but Phil if you if you said oh we've
just got a new member in our research
group and like she's giving off really
good energy I think she's gonna be
really good I wouldn't sit there and go
oh do you mean kinetic energy or
electric no and I know neither would we
all stereotypes of food physicists to
one side but we wouldn't be clearing to
be able to stand beside or three feet
away and influence or energy in so
change our state of mind which is what
he's claiming this is where a controlled
study whereby she's got some headphones
on and she's listening to some nice
relaxing music and it's playing fool and
it's completely in the dark I would like
to see if the reactions would be the
same but Phil maybe that external
stimuli the handsome man with the nice
and the nice voice
maybe that is contributing to this
cocktail of physical things that are
happening that make it work or maybe
it's the only thing and how would we do
that
how would we isolate one effect from the
other we'd do a controlled study where
you try to control the in variables in
the environment I don't trust anyone
that wears old black they outfit like
that give them that I will give him that
the man has got a key sense of style and
sartorial elegance it's got to be said
look at that how do you feel about this
being made and put out there that's a
really good question a really good
question am I worried about it I am
worried about it in terms of
disseminating that type of it's nonsense
you know it really is no scientific
basis they've got the disclaimer or
flaunt front for all of ten seconds you
know you've got that simple writing on a
black background or whatever against
incredibly attractive people you know
being you know saying my life has been
radically changed you know one is gonna
wear the other if it's a therapy if
that's all it is is a therapy and it's a
placebo and people are coming out of
those sessions and if you I feel so much
better now I'm not gonna argue with that
you know religion plays that role in
many people's lives as well my key
concern is particularly when this is
pushed as a medical procedure when it
will treat cancer
or treat other forms of disease that's
when I get really really scared and
actually we need to regulate this time
they should this be on Netflix this
should it comes back to the question of
balance I would say if they can present
the aspects of this but there really
should be a counterbalance in this
they've pretty got pretty what's got
free rein in terms of what they present
there should be physicists this should
be doctors there should be chemists
there should be whatever right across
the board saying no this is wrong this
doesn't work explain this explain this
just as were doing now we shouldn't have
to rely on sixty symbols to you know
take this to pieces that should happen
in in the process itself but of course
you know is that going to is a fully
balanced documentary like that gonna
attract any like anything like the
attention this is attracted no of course
not
where is the evidence that what he's
doing works there's no evidence at all
we've seen some people moving around the
very first step in that as a controlled
experiment where you cut out his visual
and his audible cues and do a perfectly
controlled experiment and then see how
those people behave and if honestly if
they do that experiment and where people
have headphones on and blindfolds on in
a darkened room and they move and they
have no cue at all as to where his hands
are these inference I would be over the
moon oh my that would like revolutionize
that I will get a Nobel Prize let's put
it this way I'm not going to bet the
bloody house on it that that's gonna
happen
maybe 60s and what it does is it
connects New Age ideas sort of Eastern
mysticism with quantum mechanics and
quantum physics the idea that you know
quantum physics means that there's an
interconnectedness to all things and
widows and universal spirit it's at all
these type of things